individuality gives up that
reflectiveness into self which is
expressed in lines and lineaments and
places its essence in the work it has
done here in it contradicts the
relationship established by the
instinctive reason which is engaged in
observing the self conscious
individuality ascertaining what what its
inner and outer is supposed to be this
point of view leads us to the thought
which really lies at the base of the
science if one wishes to call it such of
physiognomies the antithesis which this
observation encounters has the form of
the antithesis of the practical and the
theoretical both falling within the
practical aspect itself the antithesis
of individuality making itself actual
and it's doing doing in its most general
sense and individuality as being at the
same time reflected out of this doing
into itself in making this its object
observation accepts this antithesis in
the same inverted relationship which
characterizes it in the sphere of
appearance it regards as the unessential
outer the deed itself and the
performance whether it be that of speech
or a more durable reality but it is the
being within self of the individuality
which is for it the essential inner of
the two aspects possessed by the
practical consciousness intention indeed
what is meant or intended by the deed
and the deed itself observation selects
the former as the true inner the
intention is supposed to have it's more
or less a Sun essential expression in
the deed but it has its true expression
in the shape of the individuality the
latter expression is the the immediate
sensuous presence of the individual
spirit the inwardness which is supposed
to be the true inner is the particular
particularities of the intention and the
singleness of the being for self both
together are the spirit as only meant or
intended what observation has for its
objects is thus an existence which is
only
end and it looks for laws between such
existences
paragraph 319 is exploring an opposition
that at you might say a higher level
than the opposition or if you like
antithesis that's the term that Miller
translates gagan zotz by over and over
again there's a higher level antithesis
going on here between two different
perspectives one of which is the more
adequate perspective but which is being
overlooked the other of which is the
perspective that observing reason in
it's instinctual activity in the way it
applies itself in you might say a less
reflective unthinking way to the
phenomenon that it's attempting to study
is going to end up projecting onto what
it's what it's making sense of and this
can be understood in a contrast between
the theoretical and the practical that
that's discussed herein very interesting
ways well it will go into that this is
fair don't instinct right so this is the
instinct of reason or a reason acting in
an instinctual way and the goal is to
get beyond that interestingly what's you
know reason is is casting itself as
being sort of a higher level perspective
what's going on with the self conscious
individuality is seen as being at a
lower level except insofar as it has to
do with the theoretical which is what
reason is really most interested in at
this point so let's let's take a look at
the text itself he says individual
individuality gives up that
reflectiveness into self which is
expressed in lines and lineaments
remember we're talking about
physiognomies ear and places its essence
in the work it has done we've seen this
in the previous paragraphs what it is
that we're actually externalizing into
the world is where the essence is this
is something typically a galleon
whatever is inner must become out
whatever is presumed to be driving
things behind the scene must appear must
show itself and it is no different with
the human person so he says here in it
contradicts the relationship established
by this instinctive reason which is
engaged in what observing the self
conscious individuality why is it
observing the self conscious
individuality as we're going to see at
the end of the paragraph and in the
paragraphs to come because it wants to
derive laws about you know the
individuality but about individuality
'he's in general laws that will allow us
to figure out how people are going to
behave based on what types of people
they're going to be so in a certain way
it's treating the individual as
individual but it's also treating the
individual as generic type now the
individual him or herself is working in
a somewhat different way so let's let's
follow this out he says the point of
view of reason leads us to the thought
which really lies at the basis of
science if one wishes to call it such of
physiognomies and we don't need to dwell
too long on the fact that hagel
considers physiognomies rightly so to be
a pseudoscience so what is the
pseudoscience it's something that has an
ology to it right there's that there's
an account there's a reason there might
be all sorts of nice charts and drawn up
you know arrows connecting things and
predictions made but it turns out to be
without any real genuine basis and it's
not just that it doesn't continue to
predict out you know it's transferred
from situation situation it doesn't
provide a genuine intelligibility of the
phenomenon that's what science mission
shaft for Hagel is supposed to do
particularly when it's a science of the
human being you know guys this vision
shaft in in in in German you know
literally a spiritual science or a
science of the human being it has to
take into account
very fact that we are not only the
subjects but also the objects of the
scientific inquiry and physiognomies
fails at that so he's what he's looking
at here is what lies at the basis of it
so he says the antithesis which this
observation the observation made by
reason encounters he has the form of the
antithesis of the practical and the
theoretical and this is indeed in
opposition right now here is where a lot
needs to be said but perhaps not so much
in at this point because we're going to
see this play itself out over and over
again and I've mentioned this in in
other videos as well there are different
ways in which we can look at the
interrelation or if you like the
opposition or the antithesis between the
practical and the theoretical now one
way is to say that the practical is
really something that is is subordinate
it just follows from the theoretical
what's most important is you know
speculative reason theoretical reason
pure reason if you like and it looks at
things the way they are and then once
we've deduced some laws or we've deduced
you know some some you know schemas or
some way of thinking about things then
we gets the practical stuff and that's
just sort of a matter of application
afterwards and so if you think about you
know the way in which for example can't
structured the critiques right the first
critique critique of Pure Reason then
after that critique of practical reason
and then you know we've got the third
critique what is that about that's a
very different that's a mess right so
but I also think about Descartes even
think about people who were engaging in
the modern period in what is clearly
practical or was they called it moral
philosophy like thomas hobbes if you
read the first part of leviathan it
doesn't begin with practical philosophy
it begins with a theoretical account
which then can be used as a basis for
providing a
practical account right the card is
doing something similar in his works
we're Hagel and several other important
thinkers are going right I think is in
restoring what we can call the primacy
of the practical so what do we mean by
that the theoretical is assumed to be
better you know more essential more visa
Lika right more important more
architectonic if we want to use an
Aristotelian term but isn't theoretical
activity itself driven by practical
motives isn't theoretical activity
itself a kind of doing a kind of in the
German handle it's not just practical
things like well you know should I go
buy some shoelaces or not or what should
I do about world hunger or am I a nice
guy or a bad guy or you know all these
sorts of things that we can think about
that we might place within the realm of
the practical that are action that are
doing that our making things happen that
are motivated it's also the entire realm
of theoretical as a matter of fact even
making the distinction between the
theoretical and the practical itself is
not a purely theoretical exercise Hagel
rightly you know calls our attention to
the fact that we have a practice he
calls a practical aspect here right both
the the form of the antithesis of the
practical theoretical both fall within
the practical aspect itself the
antithesis of individuality making
itself actual in its doing doing in its
most general sense individuality is
being at the same time reflected out of
those doing into itself in making this
its object so what we've got here sort
of represented by this arrow is an
ambiguity on the one hand we can say
that the practice
call unfolds the theoretical sucks it
back in right on the other hand the
theoretical does have a certain
distinctness to it a certain raised on
depth a reason for being and it takes
what's going on with the practical and
reflects on it this is why is it in the
long run it actually turns out to be
practically speaking a little pun
they're impossible to maintain very
rigid distinctions between the
theoretical and the practical in in
philosophy because as it turns out the
theoretical is imbued with the practical
and the practical itself relies upon the
theoretical theory theorizing is going
on within that just for one example
which Hagel's not talking about here and
this is a larger scale thing I you know
I do a lot of work on Aristotle and
Aristotle does like to make a rigid
distinction between you know a
theoretical use of reason and a
practically some reason or the intellect
and he talks about disciplines is doing
that now political science you know hey
política PSMA for him is a practical
thing it's supposed to culminate
ultimately in action and when he says
action we can also think attitudes and
arrangements of affairs and you know
resolutions and things along those lines
now you might say okay so press full you
know the political science or ethics
those are supposed to be culminating in
action well is the discipline itself is
the book that you wrote here that were
reading they were puzzling through is
that supposed to lead us immediately to
action or even at the very end of it
doesn't seem so and why did you bother
studying this stuff and devoting so much
attention to it Aristotle and this is a
question that he doesn't really have a
good answer for other than you know
generality all men by nature desire to
know sure no in a theoretical sense
where there's no
practical effects or implications coming
from it right away but perhaps we can
apply it down the line Aristotle is
interested in what makes human beings
tick why are they so screwed up and how
can they become a little less screwed up
so that they can live in a society
together and start realizing a portion
of the human good now those are very
practical questions but those are also
theoretical questions we can say the
same way going back to Hegel about this
entire book now to go back to what he's
talking about in this paragraph we can
similarly say this at a sort of lower
level you know individual scale about
the action of the individual him or
herself so Hagel is going to talk about
how this plays itself out and the
practical we look at in terms of and
there's more to the practical than this
but but oftentimes we make this
distinction between the intention which
we see as interior to the person and
then it's externalization in the D the
top what it is that they actually do the
action or if you like the performance
and the performance in this case could
be Hagel mentions speech or language or
it could be some sort of reality that
that's created like a book like a tie
like all sorts of others like writing
things on the chalkboard all sorts of
other things right so he goes on and he
says here we go observation accepts this
antithesis in the same inverted
relationship which characterizes it in
the sphere of appearance it regards as
the unessential outer the deed itself
and the performance reason doesn't get
that this is where things are happening
this is the actual and he says it is
looking instead at the being within
itself of the individuality which fit
for it is the essential in ER and they
says of the two aspects possessed by the
practical consciousness in 10
indeed what is meant or intended by the
deed and the deed itself now notice the
reversal that's happening there we're
thinking of it as well there's the
intention and the intention itself is
the meaning or the intending and that
produces the deed Hagel's actually is a
good phenomenologist saying what are you
actually observing the deed you get to
see the need often times even with
ourselves you know we do something and
we're like why the hell did I do that
that was what was I trying to do when I
when I said that to that person or when
I arranged things in that way what was i
even thinking about it and we can
reconstruct this for other people
similarly we see the deed and then we
say there's some sort of meaning some
sort of intending going on there and he
says observation selects this is the
true inner the intention is supposed to
have it's more or less unessential
expression in the deed the deed is not
really essential the you've got the sort
of thinking about it and then doing and
the doing just kind of happens it's
afterwards it's not that important
what's really important is what a person
is thinking Hagel saying no no no that's
that's putting the cart before the horse
because in this case we only actually
see the horse right and he goes on and
he says here we go the latter expression
is the immediate sensuous presence of
the individual spirit the inwardness
which is supposed to be the true inner
is the particularity of the intention
and the singleness of the being for self
both together are the spirit as only
meant or intended so what observation
has for its objects is thus in existence
which is only met that's a problem
because what we want is something that's
more than just meaning or intending or
even gesturing so we're going to have to
turn to the deed and we will be doing
that in
the future paragraphs now notice what he
how he ends this like I mentioned before
it looks for laws between such
existences it looks for laws that govern
what we actually observe which that's
not really essential for for reason but
it really is for the individuality and
then the intention a kind of ghostly
thing floating in the background can we
produce laws about that well that's what
we're going to see him discussing in the
following paragraphs
the forming of opinions prema fashi
about the presumed outward presence of
spirit is natural or everyday
physiognomies the over hasty judgment
formed at first sight about the inner
nature and character of its outer shape
the object of this opinion is of such a
kind that its essence involves its being
in truth something else than merely
sensuous immediate being true it is also
just this reflectiveness into self out a
sense in sensuous form and this which is
visibly present as visibility of the
invisible is the object of the of
observation but just this sensuous
immediate presence is the reality of
spirit only for mere opinion and
observation and keeping with this aspect
busies itself with this presumed
existence of spirit with physiognomies
handwriting sound of voice etc it
connects such existence with just such a
presumed inner it is not the murderer
the thief who is to be recognized but
the capacity to be one the fixed
abstract quality thereby gets lost in
the concrete infinitely determinate
character of the particular individual
which now demands more skillfully
contrived delineations than those
qualifications are such ingenious
delineation certainly say more than the
qualification murderer thief or
good-natured unspoiled and so on but
they are far from being adequate for
their purpose which is to express the
presumed being or the particular
individuality as inadequate as the
delineations of the bodily shape which
go no further than a flat forehead a
long nose etc for the individual shape
like the individual self-consciousness
is a being that is meant inexpressible
the science of knowing men which deals
with the supposed of human being like
the science of physiognomies which deals
with his presumed reality it aims at
raising the unconscious judging of
everyday physiognomies there for
something which lacks both foundation
and finality it can never succeed in
saying what it means because it merely
means and its content is mirrored
something merely met
in paragraph 320 Hagel is is talking
about how it is that a pseudoscience in
this case physiognomies a body of
presume it knowledge about human nature
about human types about the ways in
which we can tell what people are and
how they're going to act and and what
tendencies they have he's talking here
about how it fails to do what it's
pretending to do and you know he uses a
lot of language of spirit here and it's
important for us to keep in mind is
reading this that the translator has to
make a choice in German Geist is both
spirits in the sense of being something
elevated or you know also you know
spirit and the old you know theological
sense but but it also means mind as well
similarly to how in French s plea means
mind and spirit and also wit and so we
want to keep that in mind when he's
talking in this this paragraph about how
we're observing spirit here because it's
not just the individual who's being
observed by observing reason as you know
sort of a bug under the you know the
plot of the glass or a microbe under the
microscope it goes beyond that right
where we're trying to observe human
beings and say something really
essential about them through this
presume it's science and Hagel's Hagel's
rejecting physiognomies as a science
starts not be talking about the forming
of opinions prima fashi about the
presumed presence of spirit and what
does he mean they're well opinion is
mine own and we've seen this in the
previous paragraph in terms of intention
or in terms of sort of a jest
and that's really all that's going on
when we're in the realm of mere opinion
he'll talk about this a little bit more
of the next paragraph as well but but
this is this is an important part so he
says what we're doing is we're trying to
have opinions about the presence of
spirit the presence of what it is that's
really distinctive about human beings
and it talks about natural or everyday
physiognomies the over hasty judgments
formed at first sight about the inner
nature and character of its outer shape
so you know we do this a lot and it's
good here that he's talking not just in
terms of you know developed purportedly
scientific with all the trappings that
scientists you know bring discipline
I'll physiography that might be in books
that the one might take courses on but
also the fact that people do this in an
everyday or you know less less
reflective way as well you know when we
look at somebody and we say I just don't
like the fact that his eyes are so close
together that makes me think that he's
less trustworthy we're engaging in what
Hagel is discussing here as everyday
physiognomies another application that
just sort of came to mind for me which
is quite important particularly in this
age of photoshopping and constant
imagery is the fact that we do in fact
we know this from from psychologists
studying this we do in fact tend to
trust people more who we think are
attractive in certain senses and a lot
of that turns out to be matters of
proportion and symmetry there's really
no good reason why we should do that
right I'm going to certainly no no no
rational reason why we should but we do
engage in this kind of everyday
physiognomies can play an incredible
roll with it you might think for example
about the you know the Dean
ization that's happened for four
centuries for certain human types you
know people it wasn't that long ago and
somebody who had some sort of handicap
physical problem with their frame would
be sort of singled out that's the bad
guy I know because he's showing up in
the movie and he's you know got some
sort of problem with his body he must be
there must be something wrong with that
person so this is something that we
engage in today I think just as much as
people did in hegel's time we just do it
in in different manners you can read all
sorts of you know great blog entries and
you know go to pick stuff off the
supermarket stands in various magazines
people giving you advice about how to
tell if somebody's lying somebody's this
kind of character or not and really what
we should be looking at what's not
talked about here but we did talk about
the last program is the deed the action
or even you know the way a person talks
over time there are consistent patterns
but we're not looking at that instead
we're looking at their outer shape their
lineaments particularly the face so he
goes on and he says the object of this
opinion of this my knowing is of such a
kind its essence involves it's being in
truth something else than merely
sensuous immediate being we're trying to
say something about more than just what
we are perceiving on the surface we're
saying we can like look into what a
person is and he says true it is also
just this reflectiveness into itself out
of sense in sensuous form and here he
talks in terms of this metaphor
visibility the soul the psyche the
personality is something that is
invisible and guy stiga or spiritual
things are not something that are
primarily visible so the invisible is
turned
visible as the inner is externalized
into the outer the question is what's
the relation between the inner and the
outer here you notice that it should
point out here we think that the outer
shape expresses the inner nature why
because it's presumed that the inner
nature is somehow causing the external
shape so there's a reciprocal relation
here between the inner and the outer and
it allows this like i said to the
dispense with looking what a person
actually does and to talk about how a
person appears so he goes on and he says
just this sensuous immediate presence is
the reality of spirit only from your
opinion mere opinion is getting the
reality of spirit wrong observation and
keeping with this aspect busies itself
with this presumed existence of spirit
with physiognomies with what else
handwriting sound of voice we might look
at all sorts of other things other
physical manifestations of what we take
to be inside a person is the the
examples of what Hagel is talking about
here as this broad discipline of
physiognomies we don't use that term
anymore we talk in terms of other things
you know we talk for example about
profiling people we talked for example
about having a first impression right
now and we've done all sorts of
interesting psychological studies what
you don't want to draw too much from but
you know if you do notice that the same
guy dressed in in you know a suit and
tie is treated quite differently than
when he looks like a homeless bum you
know sitting on the street I wrapped in
a blanket or something like that okay
appearances do in fact matter and why do
they matter they matter because people
are assuming that the outer does in fact
show us something of the
and the inner is what is guy stiga that
the inner is what is spirit so he goes
on and he says it constructs such
existence with such a presumed inner
does this inner really exists there's
something there right he talks about the
reflectiveness into self right okay so
self consciousness we are able to be
reflective we're able to take into
account you know how we look what we do
and they don't make an issue of that
we're able to bring that for forward in
our minds and remember it and say I want
to do this more I want to do this less
all that is true right does that mean
that we have the inner the way that
physiognomies ents it no it doesn't so
he says here he's got some great
examples it's not the murderer the thief
who is to be recognized why would the
murderer thief be recognized again how
do you know if somebody is a murder they
actually do murder somebody right then
they become a murderer how do you know
if they are a thief well they steal
stuff especially to catch them
red-handed knives our there there's a
thief right there physiognomies oh isn't
really looking at crime records or if it
is it's doing so in a very different way
because what it's interested in is the
capacity to be a murder the capacity to
be a thief what is it about our inner
character about who it is that we are
that make some of us susceptible to lose
our temper fly into a passion and take a
life or to plot the downfall of another
person precisely because we want what
they've got and we're willing to violate
certain moral norms and go against the
the fear of punishment to get it you
know what it is that we think that we're
entitled to that would be presumably
something inner to the
person and some people would have that
and other people wouldn't have that we
can talk in terms of other things too
who's got grit that's a big term that
people love today it was big thing a
long time ago and now it's come back
into fashion to talk about grit it's not
something that we can quantify you know
people are trying to do that sort of
thing but it's something that we you
know do in fact presume is inside of a
person what would display grip though it
would be only the outward action or
speech so he goes on and he says it's
the capacity to be a murderer or a thief
the fixed abstract quality thereby gets
lost in the concrete infinitely
determinate character of the particular
individual which now demands more
skillfully contrived delineations and
those qualifications are so what is he
what is he talking about in that vast
sentence right there the delineation zar
things like murder and thief but what
are we using as the index for that well
all the things that we can put here and
say this counts as being a sign this
counts as being an index for this this
this characteristic we've become much
more sophisticated in how we do this
these days we might do it in terms of
statistical analyses but it would still
be a matter of physiognomies and doing
that we also do this by the way in terms
no longer so much of bumps on people's
heads like phrenologist did or measuring
them with calipers but we do it with
other things like lighting up things in
an MRI machine or saying that a person
has a certain chemistry or genetic
disposition towards one thing or another
so what do we have there a whole bunch
of different possible signs in
you can compile them into books and and
make something out of them and so he
says these ingenious delineations say
more than the qualification murderer
thief or if we want good-natured
unspoiled and so on but they're not
adequate for their purpose what is their
purpose Hagel tells us here to express
the presume it being or the particular
individuality tell us what a person is
in there in turn eicher who they are are
they a murder are they a good-natured
person are they someone who has grip are
they somebody who lacks resiliency are
they somebody and we can go on and on
and on and on right we can we can do
this as well just in terms of the you
know Big Five dispositions we can go on
and on with this sort of thing some
people are naturally conservative and we
can lay out those those characteristics
but unless we're actually taking into
account what people in fact do we're
somewhat missing the point we're playing
around we're engaging in an imaginary
exercise and one of the big problems is
from a theoretical perspective this is
unsatisfying this is inadequate right
from a practical perspective this gets
us into all sorts of trouble when we
start making assumptions about people
based primarily on things of their
appearance that are supposed to be
expressions caused by what's inside of
them particularly if it leads us to
misconstrue what it is that they
actually do or their patterns of of
engaging in linguistic behavior so Hagel
talks here about you know people who
have flat foreheads or long noses and he
says the individual shape like the
individual self consciousness is qua
being that is meant inexpressible you
cannot deduce all that much from a nose
but these physiognomist were deducing
all sorts of interesting things how are
they doing that while they were
basically making it up in part they
would draw
inclusions based on insufficient
empirical evidence that was jury-rigged
to get them what they want but in part
it was probably a matter of you know
coming up with some sort of thing that
seemed systemic and you can understand
the motive it allows you to think that
you can understand human beings human
beings are messy and complex and often
surprise us so you know if you were a
doctor going into prisons and looking at
the people who turn up in prisons and
you know noticing certain physical types
could be that the officers arrest those
people more often or that you know those
people are more often in poverty or all
sorts of other things maybe there isn't
actually something in there and then you
know you start to draw conclusions about
outward shapes so he goes on and he says
the science of knowing men which deals
with the supposed human being like the
science of physiognomies deals with his
presumed reality and aims at raising the
unconscious judging of everyday
physiography to the level of knowledge
that's aiming and taking this this thing
that we all do anyway really without
good basis and turning it into a science
he says something that lacks both
foundation and finality it can never
succeed in saying what it means because
it is it merely means and its content is
something merely meant what's lost a
little bit in the english translation
there is that this my tongue is is
reducing it to the level of opinion and
not just opinion but individual opinion
so a researcher may write a treatise on
how certain you know facial features or
tendency to smile or frown or something
like that signify something about the
character of a person which is going to
be a real capacity that we can then
predict from it's never going to be more
than the intention the the imagination
the opinion of that particular
researcher or the other people who they
happen to captivate as a
salt so what we're getting here is a
really serious critique of physiognomies
and also later on it phrenology or any
kind of pseudoscience that is basing
itself upon these sorts of
determinations right what it is that
that we see represented in the outward
frame of the person again what's been
left out what needs to be restored is
attention to what the person actually
does